so could give me an example of bad
measurements
yeah i mean
again and again you see people look at
the wrong thing
and i think the most common thing is
when people look at users and they don't
measure the number of users properly um
now that that's true in a company that
should be generating revenue and is
looking at the number of users rather
than how much revenue those users are
generating right that happens a lot but
it's also true even with companies that
should just be looking at users when
they count users wrong they'll say
you know we had 50 000 sign ups in the
last week
right okay a signup's not a user how
frequently are those users engaging with
your product
so looking at patterns of retention
exactly i mean retention's everything
when you're looking at users if you have
people they sign up on day one and they
never come back
it looks terrible and it means you're
building a bad product something again
that's a mile wide
you know inch deep kind of thing because
no one really needs it if you have
something where you only have a thousand
users but they use it 10 times a day
now you're on to something it might not
feel as good as having 50 000 signups
but it's so much better because it's the
base that you can grow from